speaking of love another moment from the
meal that we want to share with our
viewers something
vlad revealed this is good roll it so i
have a personal milestone you know i got
married during the pandemic which was
incredible which was a milestone of
itself because i never thought this
would happen
and now we are having a baby and it's a
baby girl
hey that's news
[Applause]
i love that news
well there's some breaking news
that was so wow
tony this is funny i called vlad and i
said hey dad and he goes no gail you
called vlad i go lad you're going to be
a dad i don't think it's titled him i
know it hasn't settled in he goes no
gail you call black you can retire that
phrase you always use where i'm not a
parent but i know it's yes we'll be a
parent soon congrats january of 2023
we're welcoming our little girl and we
are very very happy i'm going to be a
girl dad which is amazing uh and we're
just very happy we're bringing it so
challenging for people to have children
yeah and yeah not always don't take it
lightly it's not easy but we're we're
very blessed we're thrilled
so happy for you both thank you guys i
can't wait till little gail duty
making a note of that right now
make it a middle name that's okay she's
upset that i was thinking natalie
natalie
natalie tonina
we gotta leave it there